right so hi I'm Sebastian Burton Stein I
mean represents MongoDB in the Wolfram
language so the first question is so
we've just seen what's how to deal with
sequel databases so a database link was
designed around an idea that you want to
have a generic interface to any sort of
sequel database so it can use Postgres
it can use my sequel anything of the
sort so I'm going to be linked and the
integration with MongoDB is a very
different philosophy
it's that here's a database MongoDB and
we're gonna make it we're gonna make
some functionality that is completely
specific to MongoDB so the design
everything is built around how MongoDB
works it's not generic to other
databases and we'll see some reasons why
this is very nice but later so the first
question is what is MongoDB and first of
all it's an open source database so you
can see the source code over there you
can read a comparison later on if you
want against my sequel which is probably
the most popular sequel database and I'm
just gonna tie myself properly so okay
I've got ten months so okay so the main
thing what this is is it's a no sequel
document store that's its main sort of
function and what that means is that you
first all don't have any schema so for
sequel you have you defined exactly what
your tables look like and if you have
changes for those tables so if examples
suppose your data has a new field that
wasn't there before then you have to do
schema migration which is annoying and
painful so it's a much more flexible
data model than what what sequel is but
you can also opt into schema if you
really want to and that can be useful
for example to make sure that date that
comes in as of a certain form and one
thing I should also mention is that
databases have sort of converged both
sequel databases and those sequel
databases to a very similar sort of
database what I mean by that is that
nothing like MongoDB has picked up a lot
of features that are traditionally in
sequel so things like joins and asset
transactions was the recent version of
[ __ ] and sequel databases like post
rest my sequel have got some form of
document database where you can
basically just say here's a JSON
document or piece of JSON and just saw
that in the database but that probably
won't be exposed by a database link I'm
not sure whether okay so it also has
other things so for example it has
support for geospatial data so for
example if you want to do geospatial
queries like finding out you know what
is what geographical points are closer
to other points and also graph database
functionality so there's a whole bunch
of efficient graph lookup sort of stuff
and the philosophy that [ __ ] is from
work towards is that you don't need many
databases you don't need a graph
database plus a sequel database plus a
document store you can sort of do
everything with with just one database
and that's also by far the most popular
no single database so this is a ranking
of a databases by popularity and yeah
it's very it's by far the biggest and
most used no sequel database okay so now
that you have some rough idea of what's
what we're talking about what I want to
show is first of all what okay sorry
so the interface to MongoDB in the
Wolfram language is this experimental
feature called [ __ ] link so among the
link is a package and Mathematica on
Wolfram language it was new and 11.3 so
if you have 11.3 you can you can have a
look and play with it by experimental it
means that it could still change a
little bits we haven't completely
finalized in the design it's also
actually open source so you can go to
our github page and actually see it and
you can go you can make requests
functionality or even you know make pull
requests for functionality that's
missing that you want to see
and myself I'm actually part of the
machine learning group at Wolfram
research and we use this internally for
managing massive data sets for all
machine learning where you have often
terabytes killed a turn and we found
MongoDB to be a very good fit for that
and also one thing that's quite
different from MongoDB from compared to
the database link stuff is that
everything is written using the C driver
using library link so there's no J link
overhead for example so every call that
you make J link costs I think like 10
milliseconds or 50 milliseconds or
something so it has it was designed to
be super super efficient and limited
matza overhead and it also has one of
the other features is that it's very
very similar the design to other MongoDB
language drivers so for example if
you've used pymongo you'll know pretty
much exactly what it do was this one and
of course there's going to be you know
there's a longer tutorial that you can
see for more information about all the
stuff
so this basically will be a very quick
overview of the functionality and I
can't really dive into yeah it's a
detail too much okay so let's say you
just get an exact example of what we're
talking about here so let's say we've
got this data so this is a list of
associations and these associations have
nesting in them so we can actually
visualize this is a data set and we can
see there's item quantity and these are
all values and size has has nesting
inside it now in sequel you can't
represent this very cleanly you have to
flatten this out somehow but MongoDB has
complete support for any sort of nested
data and it can represent them in the
database and also one thing you might
notice is that we have things like the
data objects so these are data objects
current date just evaluates to a data
objects and there's a whole bunch of
support types that we have natively in
[ __ ] link so things like associations
byte arrays data objects
infinity true/false values etc etc okay
so let's actually have a look at example
so what I'm gonna do is I'm running a
MongoDB database on my local machine and
it's very easy to install it and run it
so if you want yourself and there's
instructions on this link if you want to
run you know have a database in the
clouds there's a host of database
service called [ __ ] Atlas and I think
there's some free free tiers people that
don't want to pay for the expensive
versions so now that it's running in the
background I can connect it and the
simple connection is with this call I've
got a connection so obviously in this
case you know I can specify all the SSL
options and all the authentication
options if I need to do that but if it's
running locally I can just run this it
will find it and I can query it I can
say let me get all the database names
that insides this database so database
the MongoDB is the same thing as a
sequel database so what we're going to
do is we're gonna make a new one called
webinar demo and this brings us to the
next thing so a database is sort of a
big structure that holds all the data
and each database has a list of
collections and a collection is
basically the same as a Wolfram language
data set or a sequel table so we can see
now that there's actually no no
collections inside here yet and it will
only be created once we actually insert
some documents into this thing with some
data into it so how we do this is we
just say okay let's call this thing test
collection we can say this is now among
a collection quotes test collection in
the database of webinar demo and we can
insert some the data that we had earlier
into this collection let's run that and
we'll tell me um three documents were
inserted okay and it's also acknowledge
that it's actually got into the database
so
that's as simple as the insertion
wonders nothing complicated whatsoever
and then certian is basically you can
either insert so they're called
documents and a document is basically a
sequel row or it's a Wolfram language
Association and with insert you can
either give a single document which is a
single Association or you can give a
list of documents list of associations
which is also the same as all from
language data sense okay so that's it
that's all I did
I collect inserted it it told me that it
worked and the next thing is you want to
actually get the data out right so the
concept here is very similar again to
the iterators hold to result sets in in
database link so I just simply say [ __ ]
collection find and it gives you Backa
cursor and from cursors we can read data
so we can say read from that that cursor
and it gives me back some data and the
nesting is here everything is still
there and the dates it converted it
nicely to a date object so there's no
need to use you know there's my special
[ __ ] data object or something that you
have to convert it on all the data types
come back you can convert you know they
could convert it and they come back
correctly as the types that you used
okay so one weird thing that you might
notice is that it has this new fields
this wasn't there before
so one thing with a lot of no sequel
databases is that they they sort of
they're there something's called key
value stores what that means is that
there's a unique key for every document
that you insert so that means that I can
reference this particular document in my
collection and if there's not a unique
field like this then you know how can I
actually find this this document again
and what it does is that if you don't
specify the special field called ID and
every every document must have that it
was automatically inserted to be this
b-zone
object ID and that you can run normal on
that if you want and it will show it
basically is it's a hash of a bunch of
information so things like when you
created the document
what machine created it and whatnot okay
but this is it it's as simple as that
and if you want to get the remaining
documents and sort of reads you can say
read list and read list will give you
back all the other documents that you
have and if you try and read more from
this thing it doesn't return anything
because now the cursor is exhausted so
it's a stateful object that you can read
from okay so reading is as simple as
that now databases without being able to
query or make queries it's pretty
useless so I just want to show you
quickly two examples of running queries
so just reminder what our data said look
like and one one thing that you might
have noticed as well is that we inserted
this data set and we didn't actually
have a date object for the first four
though for the last one for postcard and
this shows one of these you can do with
this you don't have computer sequel you
basically you know you have a schema and
you force to insert things based on that
schema but for [ __ ] I wasn't forced to
insert this at all so even if this is
missing or if there's another field that
this this postcards item has it can
easily be represented and insert into
the database there's no restriction on
saying this is not allowed okay so the
most simple way of doing finds all
queries is something like this so the
query itself is an association so you
say I want item which is this guy here
item to have a value of post part and if
I do that I get back the guy with with
postcard and you can also do other
things like resume play on the same let
me find all the documents whose height
is greater than nine let's say so [ __ ]
has a whole bunch of special operators
that start with Donna that basically
allow you to do sort of operational
queries in this case this is the greater
than operator so I couldn't say size and
then dots which
indicates that there's a nesting H goes
to that and it will find me all the
documents that have Heights greater than
nine now
this language is is very rich and it's
also quite convenient to manipulate
programmatically because they're just
associations they're not some string
that's you know some sequel string that
you have to manipulate they're just pure
associations so the easy to construct
easy to add values etc and then that's
one of the sort of main design
philosophies of MongoDB is that it it
should be easy to programmatically query
these things rather than having to write
strings which is nice to do by hand but
it's not nice to do if you're doing it
programmatically
okay so queries yeah and you can read a
lot more about queries there's a very
rich parry language very similar to
sequel and the last thing I'll mention
is that there's also a very
sophisticated data aggregation pipeline
so what this allows you to do is to
basically say let me do you need to data
analysis steps that the database itself
has to do and it can optimize that
operation massively and it doesn't have
to you don't have to do that on your
computer and the reason I want to do
that is that suppose I want to find the
average of you know a terabyte of data I
don't want to do that on my computer I
want the database to do that for me so I
can set up there's a yeah there's a
whole bunch of documentation on this but
I can set up very very complicated
pipelines that the database should run
on my data to do things like averaging
or sorting or anything of the sort and
it has all kinds of out-of-court
algorithms to deal with that stuff and
here's just a very very simple example
or there's a sample operator that
basically just gets to random sample of
the of the collection so it takes the
collection it samples and says to give
me back two samples of the the data and
this is a random sample and also just
for convenience we've got something
random sample collection and then - and
that gives you facts I think very
similar so that's basically as much time
as I've got there's other topics like
you know how to update documents how to
delete them how to get statistics about
the the database operations and the last
thing that it's gonna leave you with is
that this is a very very nice graphical
user interface for MongoDB called
compass
which is a very very slick sort of
external program that you can play and
write queries with and whatnot okay
great I think that's that's basically as
much time as I've got so thank you